there is one app that I use on my iPad
every single day as an architect without
fail and that app is more folio Trace in
the next 60 seconds I'm going to share
with you some real world examples of how
you can use morpholio Trace as an
architect architecture student or
anybody in the architecture profession
first of all if you're in a meeting and
need to create an impromptu sketch you
can very quickly and rapidly open up
morfolio Trace overlay a series of Trace
paper layers and then create the perfect
sketch in a matter of seconds besides
the scale ruler and scaling tools one of
my favorite features of morfolio Trace
is the hatching tool you can quickly
overlay one of your architectural
sketches find out the exact area of
measurement from a floor plan or an
elevation and then convert that to a
square meterage rate so when a client or
Builder asks you how much is this
element going to cost you no longer have
to estimate based on 2D plans you can
actually now calculate it in real time
so completely eliminating any guesswork